[Music]
hello everyone
i just pulled up to the big mood set
and today we're revamping a bit and as
you can see i have some stuff in the
trunk and we're gonna see if it works
and go check out the ladies because
here is jachika but maybe she doesn't
want to get filmed i don't know i gotta
ask first you gotta be polite you know
you can't just assume everyone's gonna
be okay with
a camera on their face all right so this
is what we're working with
hello are you cold i am hell outside i
know
i brought i brought a sweater though but
i didn't know that's good but yeah look
at this
cute couches good job nikki
these are so cute we wanted to redo our
set like three months ago yeah
like the couches were all on backorder
because of coving i know we had to
cancel like two other couches
and then we finally got these and i'm so
excited they came
yay here's the wallpaper oh
nice we're thinking of painting this
dark green to kind of like
match the leaves in here yeah and we're
gonna use
tiff's paintings yeah i just brought
that and we're gonna cover this because
these walls are textured
so the wallpaper won't stick to it yeah
this is hard
stick which i think is it's actually
cuter to have a paint
and then this is like yeah i like that i
like it i like it i also brought a rug
or bar cart oh yeah this cute ass bar
cart that we haven't been able to use
we also have a coffee table somewhere
and two side tables
oh yeah where'd they go yeah oh yeah
here are the side tables
the coffee table i see it back there
this is so cool
how exciting finally we get to change it
no more purple even though the purple
was kind of cool and like the
the vibes that we had in the previous
set were like loungy it was cool but it
was a little
juvenile yeah it was kind of slumber
party yeah kind of want more like
hey we're grown-ups drinking drinks
adults and lounges
yep yeah that's what we're upgrading to
but i think
if we do like a murder mystery format
we'll change it just for that format and
maybe we could wear comfy clothes
get all cozy yeah in our hoodies because
we're scared i know and especially now
that it's getting colder
finally oh my gosh it's like literally
it's november
and just today no yesterday two days ago
it finally started raining and it's like
oh yeah like like downpoured yesterday
but it was sunny
i know it's my favorite weather yeah it
was like rainbow weather
favorite weather like literally out of
like the entire year all the seasons of
the year
when it's raining but then sunny which
is the fall
time it's great i could do without the
wind though
yeah it's a little too windy but then
you get to see rainbows at this time of
year
yeah i like the rainbows it's so pretty
yay okay so what's next i mean what's
first
we're gonna go to home depot get some
paint whoa all right so we're at home
depot
we're gonna look for some paint which
green should we pick what are you guys
thinking like a hunter green
everglade i think this is more the tone
yeah right
a little more blue dark everglades oh
that's the same one i picked
oh perfect so we're trying to match it
to the wallpaper that we got
and the wallpaper that we got has like
vines on it but like
the white part is kind of like blushy
pink so we're trying to make
the green match the wallpaper and we
forgot the wallpaper that's why we're
trying to eyeball it what about a
lighter one
not so dark i think we wanted it dark so
that the couch would really pop how
about this one
feel to olive yeah i think i prefer this
one over this one
which one that one yeah yeah all right
so we got our paint
and now we came to joanns
why mickey we're getting some um
canvases so that we can put the
wallpaper on the canvas since it doesn't
fit
on the wall it doesn't stick to the wall
exactly exactly that's over here we're
going to see if we can get some vine
stuff bruised up the whole set
you know i've never been here not one oh
look it's christmas time
yeah look at all oh and also at home
depot i was able to buy an inflatable
christmas tree so i was really happy
about that because now i'd have to
search on amazon for it because i
already got it
i'll show you guys later oh like an
alcoholic chocolate yeah
they kind of remind me of our junkie
mugs all right well joanne's
a fail fail
we like some mugs but then the line was
really long so it was not worth standing
in line for
so now we're off to michael's joann's is
supposed to be like for sewing and
fabrics and stuff so they don't
hobby lobby would have been better but
sunday so
oh well we're continuing our adventure
before even fixing up the set
yay we found the canvases
all right ooh look that's me hey
i love how this adventure kind of turned
out for personal shopping for being you
i can't help it it's so cool and then
there's so much christmas stuff over
here
oh i'm trying so much all right so i
found the cylinder that i've been
needing
she found some markers we're personal
shopping don't tell jess because we lost
her
but we did find the canvases so that's a
good thing and we're trying to see if we
could figure out a way to
cover this like electrical wire thing
that's like right in the middle of the
wall
look at all the germs you're in your
elements
[Music]
that's freaking cute don't tell jess
don't touch us i'm looking for nurses
these are adorable i think jess is in
look at this
for your tasty tea look at it how cute
so cute
you know girl because you really kill it
with your bullet journaling thank you
so i got a new kind needed new markers
it was my birthday okay yeah leave her
alone
it's still my birthday yep it is it's
your birthday month it's my birthday the
whole month we
we share it we just switch off next week
with you
yeah it's okay we could share the whole
week the whole monday too so you get
that
oh there we go yeah have your birthday
see all right michaels is a success
yeah he came up with her christmas
shopping birthday
yep and then i just got the canvases
that we came for
that's what we came for and this is like
everything we got
oh my gosh that's awesome and then i
have this little cinder
syndrome i can't say it cinderella
thank you for the office that's gonna be
great and then i'll show you once we get
back to the car the inflatable christmas
tree that i bought and so it's so funny
because only nikki and i did personal
shopping
this is like we're just trying to get
stuff done can we
start painting now okay this is filling
my spirit
it is the soul meter is getting here we
go we're being happy see
jess we paint better when we're happy
we're happy
here's the inflatable christmas tree i
got and then all the stuff from home
depot you see we're getting stuff done
yeah there we go mixing work and
pleasure
that's how we get stuff done look at
that
it looks so pretty and it matches the
wallpaper
we did good ladies we did good we did it
good job you good job good job good job
good job hey good job
good job hey hey you hey
good job all right so these
ladies are gonna be painting and i'm in
charge of wallpapering
these canvases so it's this one and then
these two back here and then once that's
all done
and then the paint dries we're gonna put
all the furniture in place
and hopefully everything comes out great
yeah yeah hopefully hopefully we'll see
at this oh my god i love love love love
love
this green it's so pretty and look how
it complements the pink
couch so well so the ladies painted all
that right and then we've been waiting
for the paint to dry all this time
and then i did this
so i wrapped the wallpaper so it turns
out that
unfortunately we did not get the peel
and stick wallpaper but
it actually turned out to be okay
because i stapled the wallpaper
to the canvases that we got so luckily
we had a staple gun
i did all that and then for this one it
didn't end up like fully covering it but
then we kind of liked
how the black like gray part ended up
being at the bottom so it kind of felt
a little more artistic so we left it
like that and then now
we're moving the furniture because the
paint has dried enough i'm trying to see
how we can make this work
i like it we have these side tables by
the time we have the table to
cover most of us yeah ratchet rugs
i know this rug is crazy the table is
back there
so we can build it out oh this bar cart
is so cute i wish we could see it more
it's really dusty but it's so cute i
kind of wish like we had it more
elevated so it could be
seen some more but it's okay yeah i love
building stuff
i love it i love it it is
oh cute so there's two tops
all right it's dinner time we've been
working for quite some
few hours is that proper rainbow
okay
mr green grabbed it uh oh that looks so
good i can't wait till they
it's hung up but for now we're going to
eat can we put myself
on hell yeah thank you sorry oh
[Applause]
omg look at it now
so bryce is hanging out this feather
lamp look how cute that is
it's so cute it's so cute look at this
look at that damn we did a good job
ladies and gentlemen
ladies i did not forget
you're special because i said in
gentlemen you're not part of this ladies
there we go he's a gentleman look at
that
so cute oh my gosh i can't wait for our
first
shoot me too so what are we wearing
we we have to be like super
uh great gatsby gowns and art deco i
feel like this is an excuse to get more
wardrobe
because they're like hella cute sitting
there in sweaters
if we're saying they're sweaters and
this set nah
yeah we've we've now grown up we've
elevated with this set
when to retire so christmas holiday
sweaters and like silkiness
oh yeah we should get the the one a boa
thingy
you know the feather boa oh my god i
just want one of those like headbands
that are made out of jewels
oh yeah yeah i saw this velvet jumpsuit
on lulu's that's like a
green velvet jumpsuit that's what i'm
gonna wear every day
i love it it's not completely done
though because we still have to hang
this one
it's gonna go like this and then there
we have that hanging lamp
and then all this is gonna go away
because it's cluttered
look at this oh my gosh
we did it you guys love it we did it we
did it
we did it we have more stuff too coming
yeah we do what do we have the finishing
touches what are we gonna have decanters
uh-huh what are these santas they held
a rich whiskey aka
apple juice okay yeah we're gonna fill
this it's gonna be set liquor
so it's not to be real yeah exactly and
then also some stemware
something like really pretty stemware
glass aka
glasses exactly what's the drink gonna
bring an ice bucket
oh yes i know we have an ice bucket at
home that will match perfectly here and
we will put it on this
beautiful bar cart oh yeah we need to
add a candle too
oh man i'm so proud of us i am so
freaking proud of us
in the garage that we had before i know
the
dorm room we had before the dorm room it
was so trashy
it was only supposed to last like one or
two years that's true
last one or two shoots and then the
world decided yeah
we're gonna just keep it that is so true
but it's okay 20 20
sucked ass so that's our suck ass set
true it's gonna die with 20 20. yeah
number one new beginnings month for me
oh and tiff and i have the same
numerology so it's a number one new
beginning months for her too
it might be for you too i haven't done
your numerology but yeah because you
don't care about me
you know she cares extras should i do
mine do mine yup i'm i'm that annoying
jess you have to be more annoying
more annoying whatever i'll figure it
out to try to get you to like me
oh she wants you to like your numerology
you want to know what
it is you look like that's what you
think is going to make me like you
yeah i'm going to hate you even more and
i'm kidding your hate is love getting
wow any attention
you need someone to hug look at you like
in these blankets you look like a crazy
woman yes
what's your birthday june um we're done
july
we're done june june i'm just kidding
gina tina's july i know she's the leo
that's because
you're the cancer yeah see i know that
answer
you [ __ ] anyway good night good night
good night
[Music]
you